we have a new topic today so so excited
Arizona we do it a whole new topic it's
kind of like for me I get excited at
them but these speeds like a whole
entire thing it's kind of like walking
you to a arm it's like going to a new
country and then that first moment we
like whoa so much cool stuff like
there's just all kinds of novel things
to explore and that's kind of how I'm
doing all right I hope you're living
right now before I get into this at all
okay I want to stand back and try to
sling why I'm putting these on the board
okay let's just nip play way back and
think about that going to the hole now
in my view mathematics is about the
Seeger of st. Pat happens is kind of
like the demon okay right which is why
that makes is about more than just
numbers people think masses and that
bothers you very cool crunching economy
but there's loads of bunch of bats that
have nothing to do with numbers per se
there are just Pat was there and so we
would work with the pats so for example
of what my favorite images with rock
theory so there's a whole range of
mathematics that is about knots and why
when I put you know by beautifully
followed set of headphones in my pocket
right and then come out it's just this
big old mess is there's a patent going
on there right and the DNA that makes up
your body is also like this vehicle sort
of nos not this but there's a pattern in
your body can make sense
that's how it creates every seventh one
so mathematics have seen paths something
hands are obvious so have you definitely
but we probably rent you guys what these
are playing this one this one this one
what it is these are for is what are
they for your support you recognize
therefore this poor area and these are
things like a rectangle a rhombus or
kites you guys can help me up that looks
like trying on to me and I will be a
trapeze now with students first
learnings will depending on the way they
read them sometime they learn them as
things which have no relationship to
each other it's a curse of formulas
whether they work that's cool but they
have nothing to do with each other and
you guys have come far enough and i hope
you modes of the first time well enough
then you know that they are completely
connected right they all every every
polygon the widow of comes backed out
two rectangles and triangles right
really red team's because triangles are
just half written so some of the
patterns in mathematics are obvious but
others not so much for instance if i
told you
but the part of the subject sky the
flight ticket a story of a and the
roughly I did I diplomats on the roughly
six billion billion billion atoms that
make up like what if i told you that
they were all related in some way it was
packed underneath all of you probably
know can be sideways and illegally right
they might believe me but that doesn't
make you see the pattern okay and here's
the thing though if you start to look at
if you start digging into orbital
dynamics or are mechanical wave acoustic
sets is gone or if you didn't really get
you two something called strength EV you
will find that the humble sine function
is what governs all of these you if you
take a picture of a certain this one the
sky at the same time every day for a
whole year Randy like take a picture of
the Sun at 2pm at particular spot right
the part of the Sun will trace in the
sky is a Simon and if you have a are
faster the camera if you watch an entire
stream as it vibrates it will look
exactly like a sine wave and people who
to physics though at one of the big
theories on the fundamental nature of
light objects and energy lately is it
all they are is vibrating strings hits
the negative street ok and we have the
nerve to call these things trigonometric
ratios as if measuring triangles was the
most of what they would ever do it's not
true in fact cyanic right here in a real
way they govern every single cycle and
vibration in the endless and would you
just take this two categories that's a
lot of things
so some of these are not obvious
sometimes I'm not obvious at all and
this topic is about one of the least
obvious patterns in all of that sort of
sort of wouldn't confess it so to try
and tease it out of it let me show you
this video okay so i don't know if any
of you a third arm